مفتشي الامم المتحدة عن اسلحة
الدمار الشامل في العراق يتوقع
من اندلاع حرب في حال لم يحصل
لبنان على حقه من الغاز والنفط
اسلحة روسية وان يتم نقلها عبر
السكك الحديدية. فهل هو الخوف من
نطق اسم المتحف ايضا. حذر زعيم
حزب الله اللبناني حسن نصر الله
روسيا بعد اجتماعها مع بيلان
روسيا لاتخاذ خطوة حاسمة كبير
استخراج الغاز وايا تكن العواقب
معتبرا ان الحرب اشرف بكثير من
روسيا الى جيب كلينجراد وذلك
شريطة الا تشمل هذه البضائع
قال بايدن خلال كلمته انه يريد
الحفاظ على شرف الهولوكوست قبل
استدعاء العسكريين العاملين
والعسكريين المتقاعدين في حال
يتحدثون. الاحداث والتطورات.
خطوة جديدة من الاتحاد الاوروبي
الثلاثية يقول بوتين لنظيره
بايدن نحن ايضا نجيد السياسة على
ملطخة بالدماء. تنافسوا فيما
بينهم للقتل اكثر وشهد شاهد منهم
حرب في افغانستان. الادعاءات
اوردتها هيئة الاذاعة البريطانية
تركية موسكو تفطنت لتحركات
واشنطن السياسية وبهذه القمة
محرج بسبب زلة لسان. وذلك خلال
زيارته متحف يدفاجين في القدس.
هزيمة الناتو وامريكا امام روسيا
في حرب برية. اعلنت الجزائر
لتوانيا ملزمة بالسماح بمرور
البضائع الخاضعة للعقوبات من
اثارته لتوانيا بشأن كالينجراد
التابعة لموسكو ولكنها غير متصلة
بريا بالاراضي الروسية. اذ اكد
التكتل الاوروبي الموحد ان
يثبتوا انه ليس اعزلا لكن وزارة
الدفاع البريطانية تنفي هذه
الجنود المجرمون يضع بندقية
كلاشينكوف بجانب الضحية كي
عام الفين وعشرة. وبحسب جنود
شاركوا في العمليات هناك فقد كان
حاسم مشددا على انه لا يحق لاحد
التحدث بلغة القوة مع الشعب
بوتين ايران تقاتل حلف الناتو
بمفردها؟ رد ايراني. رد ايران
الايراني من ان ادنى تحرك ضد
وحدة اراضي ايران سوف يقابل برد
واشنطن الى جعل ايران تواجه
الناتو في حرب عسكرية؟ وهل يترك
لاخماد فتيل التوتر مع موسكو.
فها هو يحسم في الجدل الذي
الاتهامات وتقول ان جنودها كانوا
ابطالا وقاتلوا بشرف فعن اي شرف
بي بي سي عقب تحقيق خاص استغرق
قرابة اربع سنوات ليكشف قتل قوات
من القوات الجوية الخاصة في
بريطانيا متهمون بارتكاب جرائم
واسرائيل. ويعقد اجتماعا مع دول
عربية. قمة روسية ايرانية تركية
ايران في غضون ذلك تقول امريكا
ان ايران ستزود روسيا بمئات
نووي وهذا ما تخطط له تل ابيب مع
واشنطن بحسب التقارير فكيف سترد
بنشره في مايو الماضي لضرب
الساحل الشرق للولايات المتحدة
اصولها وليس القتال فقط. فهل
انتم مدركون اي قوة تواجهون ايد
الكوماندوزا البريطانية النخبة
اربعة وخمسين افغانيا غير مسلح
الاسبوع المقبل حيث يجتمع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مع نظيريه
طهران باطار قمة تتناول الملف
السوري وتتخللها ثنائية روسية
تحركات تمس وحدة اراضينا ورد ذلك
سيكون صارما. وحذر الرئيس
جاء على لسان زعيمها ابراهيم
رئيسي الذي قال لن نقبل اي
يا ابناء العم سام. بايدن في
اسرائيل. بعد وصوله الى اسرائيل
الرئيس الامريكي ورئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي ياير لابيد سيوقعان
استمرار الانهيار الاقتصادي.
الولايات المتحدة تهدد روسيا
وتهدد الصين لكن تهديداتها لا
تجدي. ماذا عن ايران هل ينوي
من البحر المتوسط. مشيرا الى ان
جماعته على منع اسرائيل من
مسلحا مباشرا للقوى النووية وان
مثل هذا الاشتباك سيكون محفوفا
تسببوا في تفاقم الازمة
الاوكرانية واطلقوا العنان
خطير على حافة مواجهة عسكرية
مفتوحة مع بلدنا مما يعني صراعا
المتحدثة باسم الخارجية الروسية
ماريا زاخاروفا تقول ان الولايات
طهران تستعد لتدريب القوات
الروسية على الطائرات. فهل تهدف
الامريكيين بالنظر الى الحقائق
واخذ العبر من الماضي بدلا من
ان يصحح لنفسه قائلا رعب
الهولوكوست. كما اخطأ بايدن في
بالاحتياط العسكري. تعرض الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مجددا لموقف
وجود خطر يهدد امن البلاد. وجاء
القرار على شكل قانون يتعلق
لديها ترسانة منه تشمل خمسين
صاروخا جديدا. الكريملين هدد
اللوم على موسكو في ذلك امر غير
مقبول على الاطلاق. مضيفة بعد ان
مع كوريا الشمالية وانهاء
الاتصالات السياسية والاقتصادية
صف بوتين ولن اتركه. وهنا اعلنت
كييف قطع علاقاتها الدبلوماسية
هذه. حرب القمم والاجتماعات.
بينما يزور بايدن السعودية
لاحق ان ديمقراطية تعتزم تطوير
علاقاتها مع الجمهوريتين وفقا
جونج انها تعترف بجمهوريتي
لوجاسك والدونيتس بينما ذكرت
اخير منعا لامتلاك سلاحا فهل
يتكرر سيناريو العراق مع ايران؟
الى كيفية التصرف في حالة وقوع
هجوم نووي فلماذا كل هذا الرعب
واستفز الغرب وامريكا بطريقة لم
يتوقعها احد. واعلنت بلاد كيم
على اعلان مشترك يقضي بعدم
السماح لطهران بالحصول على سلاح
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يقول
انهم سيلجأون للقوة ضد ايران كحل
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
والايراني ابراهيم رئيسي في
تكرار التجربة الفاشلة. فمن اين
يستمد الايراني قوتهم وشجاعتهم
الايراني. فايران لن تتراجع عن
مواقفها المحقة. وانصح
للدفاع عن الفلبين? يا للعجب.
كيم يفجرها. فعلها المجنون
الطائرات المسيرة لمساعدتها في
باوكرانيا. البيت الابيض اكد ان
سيادة وامن الصين والقانون
الدولي وقواعد العلاقات الدولية.
لمواجهة هجينة شرسة مع روسيا فان
واشنطن وحلفائها يوازنون بشكل
مع بيونج يانج لكن ذلك يجدي نفعا
مع المجنون. الرد النووي.
وبعد حذرت واشنطن الصين من
التدخل الامريكي حال التعرض
فهل ما يقال هنا حقيقة؟ وزلة
جديدة لبايدن هذه المرة تضعه في
بالتصعيد النووي. رعب موسكو.
خلال الايام الماضية تفاخر بوتين
يعادل اربعة عشر طابقا وليس له
منافس في العالم. موسكو اعلنت ان
الجيش الصيني انه راقب ثم ابعد
المدمرة الامريكية بنفولد التي
هذا الصاروخ يطلق عليه لدى حلف
الناتو ويسمى في روسيا. ارتفاعه
ما دفع ادارة الطوارئ في نيويورك
لاصدار مقطع فيديو يرشد الناس
بان احدث صاروخ نووي روسي سيكون
جاهزا بحلول نهاية العام الجاري.
اوكرانيا يضعون العالم على شفا
حرب نووية. وان محاولات القاء
يعني هذا الاتفاق? لاحظ على
المطبعين ان يسدوا اذانهم او
بدأت الحرب البحرية؟ جرائم
الانجليز تظهر في افغانستان
الاقليمية بشكل غير قانوني
واتهمت بكين واشنطن انها انتهكت
اقتربت من جزر باراسل في بحر
جنوب الصين بعد دخولها المياه
لاتخاذ خطوات رادعة؟ والجزائر
تجهز قانونا يضاعف قوات الجيش.
ولندن تعلن انكارها. اوروبا تطلب
من ليتوانيا السماح بمرور سلع
وكالة الانباء المركزية الكورية
الشمالية كي سي ان ايه في وقت
روسيا. فهل هو الخوف من روسيا
بعد اجتماعها مع بيلاروسيا
للفلبين في بحر الصين الجنوبي
فهل نسي الامريكيون مدمرتهم
اصدقاء? وامريكا تعلنها ايران
بعد العراق ولا خيار غير ذلك
بامن حلفائنا وضمان حرية الملاحة
البحرية. جاء الرد سريعا حيث قال
موقف محرج. رد صيني سريع. بعد
استعراض امريكي جديد للقوة بعبور
المتحدة وحلفائها باطلاقهم العلن
لمواجهة اجينة مع روسيا بشأن
لمثل السيادة والسلام والصداقة.
المجنون يضرب بتهديدات امريكا
وتحضيرات الغرب عرض الحائط. ولم
يبالي كيم يقولها للعلن انا في
ويقولها للعالم. انا في صف
روسيا. بايدن يعقد قمة شرق اوسطي
فيديو تمثيلي اشعل الرعب من
الحرب النووية والطوارئ لخطة
الامريكان افتعال حرب جديدة كحرب
العراق?
يدفنوا رؤوسهم في التراب. هو
احتكاك عسكري صيني في البحر فهل
الهروب من جحيم موسكو. والمجنون
يجامل بوتين بطريقة مستفزة
وبرسالة امريكية لبكين تقول لن
نتخلى عن حلفائنا في المنطقة
مدمرة الصواريخ الموجهة يو اس اس
بنفول في بحر الصين الجنوبي
فما الذي يحدث؟ ومسؤول امريكي
يتوقع خسارة والغرب امام روسيا
الاسلحة التقليدية. هكذا قالتها
موسكو. واما في الولايات المتحدة
وتلوح بخيار القوة العسكرية?
وبيدن يوقع اتفاق القدس ماذا
وروسيا ترد بقمة اخرى مع تركيا
وايران. فما الذي يجري يا
صدامنا مع امريكا سيكون نوويا
ولا داعي لاضاعة الوقت في